je m'appelle cassandra scilly et
j'aimerais vous présenter ma ville où il
fait si bon vivre
bonjour derby tu devenu un beau garçon
didon qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
toi je vais chercher mon colis ici nous
sommes entourés de milliers de milliers
de clips au courant d'hectares de champs
de blé de canola le facteur a été abattu
mourey le courrier tout a disparu
donc vous avez une vidéo sur laquelle se
déroule un meurtre même si c'est le
premier meurtre que je vois dans cette
ville c'est vrai est abîmé un art qui va
vraiment touché tout ce fric en bois et
bien de quoi changer de vie maintenant
je dois voir le maccabi et tout sera
réglé
est-ce que tu manigances quelque chose
tu aurais pu [ __ ] ta caméra n'importe
où
et comme par hasard tu filmes un crime
qui va être apporté dans cette ville les
citoyens se sentent concernés toutes les
pièces du puzzle sont encore à mettre en
place
j'aurais apprécié que tu me dises où je
pouvais retrouver mon colis il faut
qu'on quitte la ville ce soir bien
dangereux meurtrier en viennent elles
prochain sur sa liste c'est moi
prendrai toujours son temps
biscotte banques et moi peu importe
l'endroit